welcome back everyone dink-dink we miss
you guys he's like just fell out of the
thing all right that's such a great
start to the episode thanks Mike keep
the back in one great guy Mike this guy
Mike say welcome back to the gingely
podcast the podcast where sometimes our
Mike's just commit suicide while we
podcast this episode is brought to you
by texture kind of texture is the future
for magazine reading and as an app that
lets you tap in the world's most popular
magazines anytime anywhere using this
your smartphone or tablet with the
texture app you breeze through hundreds
of your favorite magazines all in the
comfort of your own millennial device
true go to texture calm flash annejulien
right now to start Ben's reading on all
your favorite magazines you get a free
trial when you go to texture to our
console is generally texture the
official sponsor one of the official
sponsors of the podcast but also of
Julien's like sometimes ability to light
things on fire texture has made it so
there are no magazines here for you to
light on fire to it that is an airtight
point for anyone that's been watching
our vlog miss you know we had some close
calls we're also getting scolded in that
comment section though cause like we're
literally making a joke about it like
yeah obviously no one wants anything to
catch on fire please don't take our
funny conversation is us not taking fire
safety series that's what we reamed
about three winters
yeah there's a genuine accident I mean
you don't need to take fiery safety to 0
because then it's not fun oh you don't
fire safety safe but also fun oh my god
so we're gonna we're gonna do some stuff
if I'm a little draggy or this is a
little shorter whatever it's because you
know fog misses it's a it is it's really
out of us yeah and I was a day ahead and
now I'm like a day behind my vlog should
have been up this morning it's not up
yet me too me too
it's been
it's been weird because you have the
schedule like the massive schedule
increase of work load for vlogmas but
then you also have everything else
normally carrying on yeah it's very busy
yeah it catches up with you so my
apologies it's okay John
we love you oh if you want to touch
fingers all fishy-fishy chance here we
go so I kind of wanted to make this a
weird things podcast because you guys
requests conspiracy theories all the
time which sometimes are a little bit
difficult to come by because the good
ones are all well researched and you
know it takes a lot of effort to make a
conspiracy theory that's good that
really like hits you in that like
mind-blown place but there's a ton of
other stuff on the internet that I waste
my time looking at and looking up as I'm
sure those of you that are fans of the
conspiracy theory podcasts are also
interested in but they're not really
theories they're just strange things
that I like wasting my time reading
about some of them are supernatural some
of them are completely realistic and
some of them are just a little weird so
I thought we could I'm gonna tell you
what I found and you tell me what you
think and we can talk about it I like it
yeah thank you for compiling this weird
list I like that everything that really
interests us literally what I do in my
free time just but everything that's
interesting to us you know in one way or
another just kind of boils down to weird
well yes I'm I'm on a never-ending quest
to find the things that people can't
explain those are my favorite things it
really doesn't have to even do with
conspiracy theories which I have a deep
passion for it just has to do with
anything that people can't explain I
think I'm a gigantic fan I was
intriguing I agree I think when you come
to something that nobody really knows
exactly what it is or how does that's my
favorite this see this is why I watch a
lot of like Dateline and like you know
murder shows like I'll sit up at night
and watch these things and I'm like what
is wrong with me like is this like
murder porn like why am i watching why
am i so interested in it and sometimes
it's just that you can't explain why
you're Howard leaves me out I don't
think there's any
innately weirder or like off about
someone who's who's intrigued by
something like that like you know if
anything it's I feel like it's natural
humans are voyeuristic they're curious
they want to find things that kind of
baffle them they want to like be
challenged and so inquisitive yeah but I
mean just like teaching well it's like
you think things like that that can't be
explained they make you feel small and
not a bad like oh I'm nothing way but
more like holy [ __ ] I'm so insignificant
there's so much more out there that's
why I love shooting clouds because it's
like they make you feel so insignificant
they're so big and monstrous and you're
like look at us like 24/7
hey because I'm looking for UFOs but
also be because I genuinely enjoy just
looking at the sky and stars like you're
saying I've never been to Oklahoma with
some of those crazy skies because those
storms I've never seen like a whole
shelf of clouds but I've seen a lot of
googly eyes and a big reason why I'm
intrigued by clouds and large clouds and
big cloud formations is because when you
look at something like that there's
something so like visceral about being
you know in the presence of something so
massive yeah and you see it with your
own eyes yeah you're right there you're
the biggest thing I can imagine man
you're right in front of me we had that
conversation a while back when you're
talking about clouds because you were
really excited about like big storm
clouds in LA and I was like dude these
are these yeah for Los Angeles they were
very big yeah but when you are in the
presence of like a storm storm which I'm
sure a lot of you have seen like at the
one that I'm thinking of in particular
was uh when I worked at the day camp in
Boston and it was coming over the water
and it was like you know you you'll see
a storm or something I've never been in
a hurricane I've never been in a tornado
but it all of a sudden it goes from wow
that's something to you feel fear like
inside of your stomach yeah and and in a
way of like I don't know what's going to
happen right now like seeing a storm
that sighs just like really puts fear in
you it's crazy
yeah and honestly like I've I've
considered you know actually I probably
will at some
but I've considered multiple different
races tomorrow well they have storm
chasing yours nuts they have tours and
I'm going a few storm chasers on Twitter
because a lot there's a lot of them that
have found who are really good about
documenting the different clouds of
seeing the different formations that the
pre storm clouds the post army
scientific perspective but they break it
down on Twitter in a way where you're
just like I kinda understand everything
but they have tours and I would do it I
would [ __ ] do it I just don't know
like how it work not like a tornado
though right family it's not like like
they have they have storm chasing tours
in like Oklahoma that I would love to go
like Tornado Alley [ __ ] yeah yeah wait
but I mean you're with professionals you
know I'm okay you know you're gonna just
don't get caught up shit's creek without
a paddle
why don't you need a creek shits Creek
what an [ __ ] did it's probably really
good there probably is a Greek name no
there has to be yeah because of the same
yeah if you drive from Boston to upstate
New York you see some goofy ass [ __ ]
creeks it's like dead woman floating
Creek and you're like tight dog no
there's not yeah there is they're all
weird kinds of [ __ ] creeks and [ __ ]
up there they name any sort of like
running little Brook and they're like
yeah this is a man sitting up straight
Creek and you're like dude is it all
official or is it just arbitrary is they
have their little signs on the side of
the road interesting I'm interested you
know there's a road sign in New England
that I've never seen until I moved there
it says thickly settled do tell me if
you see a road it's yellow and it says
thickly settled what does that mean
means the snow is probably thick or
something I don't know it just means
like densely populated what we really
likely settle settled like a settlement
thickly settled that's weird
I mean a preacher I'm trying to be angry
that is where we worried that signs
you're right I mean the van and softball
and his the first time I'd ever seen it
and I thought it was a joke I was like
oh sick [ __ ] street sign fan dickly
said although I was thinking to meant
something about like the trees or
something like what does that meet
thickly said it must be super out
theater
Russ's it rolled out because there's no
way that no they're all over the place
so you're you're driving down a road or
whatever and then you come to a town and
it just says thickly settled instead of
like you're now entering [ __ ] this
part of Connecticut it'll it'll say that
and then you'll get to the town and it
says thickly settled
I think it's referring to neighborhoods
do you mean yeah
low-key thickly settled low-key thickly
settled though yeah that's weird anyways
let's get into some weird thing is okay
so uh the first thing that I found is
called quantum entanglement my source
here is Popular Mechanics calm let me
just operate it to you it's the best way
to whatever here we go
quantum mechanics suppose all oh this
okay I'm basically just reading it to
you quantum mechanics boasts all the
sorts of delightfully odd features
there's the fact that two separated
particles can interact inter
instantaneously a phenomenon called
quantum entanglement
Einstein disparage the theory which he
called spooky action at a distance but
there is significant evidence to support
the theory of quantum entanglement and
there's another phenomenon called
quantum superposition yeah this particle
this principle of quantum mechanics
suggests that particles can exists in
two separate locations at once term like
atoms we're like little [ __ ] you know
the articles physicists from Stanford
University have now demonstrated the
superposition of a group of atoms over a
greater distance than ever before 54
centimeters or about one point seven
seven feet the largest distance ever
achieved before this was less than a
centimeter so this is a big deal yeah
quantum superposition is made even more
perplexing by the fact that it can only
occur when the particles are unobserved
[ __ ] dude no listen simply by
observing a particle in two different
quantum states you caused what is known
as a wave function collapse and the
particle again exists in only one state
or the other and in case of
superposition only one physical location
or the other there for measuring the
particle in soup
position is incredibly difficult
according to the gets better according
to the Telegraph UK Russia is aiming to
use this type of technology to create
teleportation with the goal being by
2035 for in about 20 years
conspiracies around this include so if
you're if you're going to make this for
teleportation first of all that's crazy
that this is already possible that you
can make the same particle or atom exist
in the same place at the same time they
can prove it except the only thing that
makes it not possible is observing it so
I have a question about that what like
on a scientific level what about
observing something I mean you can look
into this wavefunction collapse if you
want me to Wikipedia this no no we don't
have to I mean it's just
alright in quantum mechanics
wavefunction collapse is said to occur
when a wavefunction initially in a
superposition or several something word
I can't read up here certain reduced to
a single something word or observation
in essence it's a measurement of quantum
mechanics and connects to the
wavefunction with classical observables
like position and momentum collapse is
one of two processes by which quantum
systems evolve in time the other is
continuous evolution fear the
Schrodinger equation it just it makes it
collapse I don't know how else to
explain it to you in a way that either
of us could possibly feel like there's
nothing that we can find right now that
would make either of us understand why
that's the thing well you have to have a
thorough understanding of quantum
physics which you don't get right now I
mean I took it but I don't [ __ ] know
it
you took quantum physics ah no I took
the one between that and physics so
physics HP physics no the one words like
harder than physics okay
what's that one called the Move part of
them physics it's called a harder than
physics not not like I can you know just
harder than physics yeah something hard
them physics ethic um that's really
interesting but yeah I feel like we I
would need like my cousin she's studying
I believe it's quantum physics at MIT I
feel like I need
like a genius like that to kind of just
sit me down well even then it's hard to
understand because you have to
understand the formulas whatever is
there is ways just okay but like
everyone can understand what this is
saying right yes you understand what
this is saying that they've been able to
make a particle exists in the same place
at the same time and that by observing
it it makes it collapse so that it only
appears in one physical state at one
time mm-hmm you understand that right I
forget that you understand how [ __ ]
crazy that is well yeah yes I do
I understand so Russia's looking this is
what's crazy Russia is looking to
harness this technology for people to do
20 years to be able to teleport that's
that's reaching is it though is it 20
years ago was what 1995 six what year is
it
in 96 we had no cellphones
we had no like really fun laptop shitty
laptops maybe desktop computers and
technology not advances in literally
this is the same type of thing no I
agree I think I think reading something
that is cool because it's like oh it
could really happen
I just think 20 years is like whoa look
at this you have one of the most
powerful devices in your pocket every
single day yeah but look look look it's
still right here it's not moving it's
not teleporting no but babe it's
possible I'm blown away by it all I'm
saying is 20 years I would I would bet
higher okay but let's not get bogged
down by that I want to talk about the
fact that they can make two particles
exist in the same time in different
places that's insane
so it's it's eggs it's one particle and
it's kind of just being duplicated yeah
in two places so when it exists so say
it exists right here right here position
could reach almost two feet apart right
so see one's existing right here was
existing right here Yeah right all the
characteristics of all the
characteristics about a particle a or
the particle before I was duplicated or
brought over here whatever are those are
though
was then assumed by the second particle
or do you even refer to it as the second
party so this is the thing so obviously
there's a lot of conversation about
teleportation on the internet and some
conspiracies around this include if you
go in a certain way like say Julian
walks into the teleporter teleportation
station here and you want to go to Paris
France that the you that comes out on
the other side may either physically not
be you or mentally emotionally
psychologically not be there's so much
room though for things to get jumbled
and makes it up here's what that brings
up in my mind is if there's no guarantee
in this technology or sort of turn of
events that you know particle B or
particle 2.0 is going to be the same
makeup and nobody knows that so
considering that we could have already
been do we could be doing this right now
there can be this it could exist in
teleportation former now but there just
might be different versions of us that
we're not mentally inside of them well
that's parallel universes and all of
that
no no I'm talking about like I'm talking
about like this this energy this this
science was harnessed into a form of
teleportation right and in trying that
there was no guarantee that the the
teleported person or molecule is the
same mentally or sentient Li is that a
word as as the person who was duplicated
or way so right what I'm saying is
basically right now there could be a
Jenna who was teleporting across the
world but you're not mentally her so she
could just be there I mean if that was
the case I feel like via the internet
we'd find a lot of people that were also
other people I don't think in plain
sight like you were me could've had a
ton but I'm saying it could be it could
have it could be right now it's possible
possible I mean there's also theories
about time travelers and all that so
it's anything's possible that it's
totally a thing that happens now yeah
but I think it's insane that so say
let's just play along for a second plane
that Russia develops teleportation by
2035 I mean doesn't that just make make
the whole military like everything you
have to rework everything yeah you can
change it imagine how many people would
just teleport into the White House and
be like sup dude like that's insane yeah
you have to I mean you have to rework
well you'd have to figure out a way to
block people from teleporting and you'd
also because this is how the world works
have to figure out a way to make a
bajillion [ __ ] dollars off of it yeah
it cost money to teleport advertising
you know a select few people would have
the ability to run that system like you
don't get to just sit in your house and
play quantum mechanics and quantum
physics and build yourself a little
teleporting machine you'd have to go pay
a [ __ ] ton of money to go use that
technology which sucks took electric
cars like Elon Musk was saying in a
interview that he did that was like in
the future with AI and stuff we can't
have this technology be you know
exclusive to a handful of people this
needs to be everyone's information yes
because then it just leads to evil and
it leads to people doing the wrong
things with it because teleportation
that technology if someone has it and
hoards it I can lend yourself to so many
problems well that's really interesting
I mean I but imagine so your Russia and
you're like look now is the time we can
just go invade America and do whatever
the [ __ ] we want like everybody's [ __ ]
because we can teleport and nobody else
know if the people coming here yeah all
of a sudden get here and are like
totally [ __ ] different like maybe
they have arms coming out of there like
middles or they're just mentally they
forgot what they were doing here or they
think that there's someone else that's
like that's insane that's crazy to think
about that's crazy to think about
especially because you know it's like
one of those things like I said if this
were to happen in the near future who
knows when when you like when like if
you met a person and you're like did you
teleport
are you the teleported person right are
you real right
were you born free teleported like
people could the the population could
just shoot up I mean doesn't that just
give a whole new meaning to when you
meet someone you never judge a book by
what chapter you came in on it gives a
whole new meaning to everything you know
what I mean like when you meet someone
you're meeting them at a particular time
in their life a lot of factors are going
into who you're actually meeting at that
time but maybe that person's been
jumping and jumping and jumping around
the world and they're seventy billion
times removed from the person that they
were born as yeah like you wouldn't even
know your own parents anymore because
maybe they don't even [ __ ] remember
you as well right yeah that's a good one
anyways that was weird thing number one
it's already a thing people are already
trying to use it Doug all right weird
thing number two this okay I was on this
website for a long time like so much
longer than I want to admit but it is
the consequences of sin in relation to
Karma
and it's from the website spiritual
research foundation org most of it is by
His Holiness dr. giant Balaji Athavale I
don't I'm sorry if I'm saying that wrong
but um I was originally looking up so
you know we did that podcast about what
happens after you die and that was
really interesting so I know of a couple
of theories but I was looking hoping to
find some more and instead I found this
hole that I went down about what happens
before you're born and I've heard
theories of like you choose your parents
or you choose your life or if you're
being reincarnated that that's in a
certain order and this I like I it was
one of those moments I don't know how
much time you spend on the internet but
my jaw dropped
like literally dry literally dry like
you came home and I was just sitting in
my computer with my mouth open it was
some cake let's get together and hear
this all right so um I was reading about
sin and karma and like how do you get
good karma and bad karma and that kind
of thing and it's like oh you know every
day we we gain a certain amount of karma
everything that you kill is bad karmas
like insects and like boiling water
you're killing microorganisms and all of
that sort of not gets null by the end of
the day but the only way to like get rid
of that bad karma is to put out good
karma like giving gifts and like being
good person and helping other people but
that also some of the things I didn't
know included just like having bad
thoughts or like ill-will towards other
people in your mind in your mind I
didn't know that you could you could see
anything
karma yeah you could sin in your mind
yeah without doing anything and the way
that it was written on this particular
website right [ __ ] the way that it was
written on this particular website you
said that it's a quote waste of God's
resources so if you imagine that God
gave you consciousness your brain and
you bring it and you're using it to make
negative thoughts about someone else
you're wasting God's resources and in
that sense it's punishable and is a sin
I mean god I don't know what you're
calling waste but I think this is a good
use of my brain so I started digging a
little farther so it's like okay I need
to just I want to know the information
available to me about what is a sin now
that my mind is completely blown so this
was something interesting that I found
why are people who sin not punished
right if karma is you know running the
whole everything why do you have these
people that do terrible things but like
nothing bad ever happens to them this is
the explanation for that we see
criminals corrupt people or officials
and politicians etc performing many
sinful acts and yet enjoying the
luxuries of life why do these people not
get punished for their sins is a
question that upsets many these people
are happy because of the merits of their
previous birth even God can do nothing
until the stock of their merit is over
however once the stock of their merits
is over they have to face the
consequences of their sinful acts in the
form of diseases poverty suffering in
hell or petal after death etc and short
no one can escape sins
despite the merits from the previous
births since their tendencies are evil
negative energies gain control over
their mind and intellect and reinforce
personality deficits in them
consequently they commit
more and more sins there by exhausting
their merits very quickly once their
merits are exhausted negative energies
surround them from all sides take them
under their control and inflict
different kinds of distress on them even
after death such individuals suffer in
hell for many years so basically if
you're thinking of someone who's a bad
person you're like why are they not
getting theirs they either have gotten
theirs at one point in their no they
will in their next a lifetime with a
lifetime after that once their good
karma or merits have run low got it
which is crazy yeah so then some of this
reading like made me feel really kind of
messed up because it was like if you're
born like this or you have a disability
or you're you know an animal or
something it's because you did something
[ __ ] up but you want to makes me
remember because it's a past life right
but that's like so some of these
explanations or uh what you get born as
it's like it's hurtful to me as a person
because it's not what I believe that's
like saying that when someone is deaf
it's because they did something terrible
in their life or their glass-like I'm
not sure to subscribe to this yeah
really sort of like it [ __ ] me up
because or you're you're a cow because
you did this like I also I also just I I
just really describe to that logic I
mean in terms of like a religious what
we're doing what we're doing right now
though is the sin so we can get to that
but if you do believe any of this that's
fine and I respect your ability or your
desire or your religion or whatever it
is it just hurts my soul a little bit to
understand you know what I mean ya know
I'm I'm not going to come out it's so
hot I'm not going to have a conversation
about whether this is right or wrong or
what it what do I believe or what you
believe just I've only believed anything
but all I'm doing is just reacting to it
like I think it's kind of giving echoes
I found this chart don't read it you're
cheating
I found this chart so it says
consequences that have to be faced in
the next birth or hell because sin
incurred sin committed by a woman
inappropriate behavior with the husband
if you talk angrily
with the husband according to this chart
in your next life you will be born deaf
that were in poverty for seven births or
if you're born an animal you get born as
a [ __ ] or a vixen so hold on
how much cueing with your cuts how many
times you have to argue to get seven all
it says is talking angrily was with the
husband so if one woman mouths okay
someone tiny [ __ ] crazy yes this is
maybe what some people really do believe
though so be sensitive to that so you
there are many cultures and religions in
our current world that do not treat
women like we do here absolutely I know
that yeah for sure and they don't
there's nothing wrong with that
to them to them maybe there is she
because we have a different way of
believing yeah so you know just it is
what it is but I think you can get an
idea from this chart um this would like
made me laugh out loud though eating
alone without sharing with the husband
what is it about the husband it's not
visually into husband if you do that so
we're which I've done many a times guess
what your consequences the next lifetime
you were born as a bat that eats
earthworms first and then later its own
excrement so what if I don't want a
husband I don't know baby
I don't know but because I eat alone
sometimes and don't share with you I'm
gonna be I'm gonna be a bat at the at
the least like if I cross my fingers I
can be a bad because some of these
difference of this I already told you
can you repeat it it is spiritual
research foundation.org hi I'm sorry
because I'm like normally really like
accepting of theories and I just I can't
with this one okay um
adultery eyeing other men with desire I
do that means that you would be born on
many men means that you would be born
into poverty one with a squint in the
eyes like you're a surfer I guess so if
you commit adultery you are born as a
bit
so according to this theory PG is a
[ __ ] she committed Hotel circuit
nakatsu we should add our own versions
of these go ahead I mean there's a lot
there's a fair amount but I just want to
read you some of them before yeah okay
no no I'm just thinking of them I got
some good ones I think that are pretty
good sins committed by a man if you get
married for a second time you have bad
luck for seven births one seven one
eight No if you force a woman to abort
you will face infertility in your next
life and if your son is born if you're
born like you have a son he will have a
short life um if if you as a man commit
or if you lustfully watch another
woman's face you will be born in your
next life with an eye ailment that's
right blessed if you have a physical
relationship with your brother's wife
you will be born as a donkey followed by
birth in the snake species and he'll in
the end oh this is this is just airtight
logic all over the place okay so if you
notice how much the other person is
eating who's the other person don't know
I don't know but why is what is the area
what scenario are we in we're noticing
another person and what they're eating I
think it has to do because you seven
births world no no that wasn't the
consequence I didn't tell you the
consequence yet I'm just the
consequences blindness okay seven births
is blindness no no no no no just went
what only one person yeah yeah some of
them have seven births there's only one
so far
this one's just blindness I think it has
to do with the ego and jealousy and that
kind of thing cuz those are sin so if
you're noticing how much someone else is
eating and feeling some type of way
about it you're comparing yourself you
can be blind noticing how much the other
person is eating they're gonna be like
who ever notice that all the time how
you not supposed to notice what what
someone else is eating or how God and
that's in the views of the power I gave
you to look with your eyeball to waste
of are you looking okay um friendship
with sinners was a big huge page on here
that I read about you're gonna be born a
donkey um if you commit betrayal against
anything it just says betrayal you will
be born
as someone that vomits after meals God
right um if if you steal water you will
be born as a crow if you steal anything
you will have poor nails torn and poor
nails if you steal fruit you will be
ugly or you will be a wild at home if
you steal milk you will have leprosy if
you steal honey you will be an eagle
which sounds don't all right can we go
steal some honey I want to be an eagle
tomorrow um if you steal food you have
spleen disease also along with water if
you steal household household articles
and utensils you will be born a crow if
you steal books you will be blind on
articles that are on a death bed which I
don't know what that means you'll have
less life imprisonment if you steal gold
you will have urinary disorders and
diabetes why cuz pee is gold
I don't know that has to be their logic
on I just mean it and like I'm sure I'm
trying to like it they may have a system
for out these punishments work but for
the gold come on like you pee go golden
shower come on
wow that's that's a I agree with that
like it hurts me a little bit for
someone to sit down and try and explain
what's gonna happen to you or you know
that some people in certain or some
animals or some anything is less than
you know what I mean like it just sucks
yeah for me
yeah I just don't like that I don't like
it either it makes me feel weird that
you start on teach them but the one the
bottom on the list I I subscribe to that
one well you could also want the one
over here it says if you watch the
genuine podcast you get a free trial at
texture calm boy you did not you do so
in this life you don't have to wait till
the next life also if you watch a
different podcast you can oh right now
concluded texture calms last genital you
get immediate entry to all the top
magazines you may want to read billboard
aw
it's magazine guys from my Brides out
there or my Brides magazine fans out
there check it out they have eating well
Magazine Entertainment Weekly Esquire
fitness magazine Forbes fortune I mean
all the top magazines on an app I mean
I'm kind of blown away that it hasn't
existed until texture but texture has
made it so easy they don't not they not
only let you like subscribe to your
favorite magazines but they will also
curate certain articles based on what
you've been reading occas texture has a
team of editors that will do that try to
suggest new reads for you so you're
constantly getting fed new material it
is a really easy app texture is entirely
digital so it's super environmentally
friendly you're not wasting all this
paper which like Jenna said could also
be maybe in the wrong spot when you're
being stupid and I don't have a
fireplace your house but don't worry
about that with texture right now guys
you can get free entry with a free trial
go to texture comm slash Jenna Julianne
right now and let us know how you like
it I personally love it and I think
everyone at some point just needs to
make the switch here and thank you
texture for putting up with our [ __ ]
thank you texture / thank you for
putting up with these fire segues
[ __ ] lit speaking of lit you guys are
there you go again you guys wanna get
ironing I don't have anything here if
you want to get lit on Christmas and
look nice and ugly Christmas sweater
doubt or lungi doubt go to tipsy elves
guys tipsy elves are the amazing sponsor
from what was it last week or two I
think two weeks ago and they gave us
onesies we have these Christmas onesies
they're very stylish stylish and they
have really really quality material
they're not crappy onesies tipsy elves
makes all the ugly Christmas sweaters
all the fun they've really fun Christmas
sweaters they have goofy things but
tipsy elves is just kind of like a
different style that I feel like doesn't
really exist out there and it's an
awesome awesome one they have a whole
selection they even have like full suits
like dress up suits but there are there
like tipsy elves or holiday themed and
they're really cool you can all right
now go to tipsy elves calm and check
all new to 2016 sweaters and onesies and
everything they have just if you record
in front of a green screen maybe don't
get a green one like I did because that
wasn't the smartest thing right now you
guys get 20% off tipsy elves calm on
anything you order tink fam gets 20% off
so if you get an ugly Christmas sweater
get it from tipsy elves because you will
be happy they have awesome designs and
their quality is not to be beaten and
you don't have to leave your house you
don't know yeah order it well it's also
one of these things where you could see
all these cool potentially cool-looking
Christmas sweaters or whatever online
but you never know how hungry the
quality is with tipsy elves your gain at
awesome quality fee free paper bikini I
want to wear their stuff going to tipsy
elves calm enter code JJ at checkout and
you get 20% off site-wide and then you
can be a tipsy off and get all tipsy and
lit oh there's my segue just came a
little late our other sponsor this week
is the amazing top-of-the-line best sock
in the world Stan's socks
I love Stan's so much I feel like Stan's
has kind of opened a whole world for me
to wear socks and express myself with
their socks they have such amazing
designs and Rihanna has a clock Gianna
has a line with Stan's they make gone
mom I feel like I speak for a lot of
people and I say before seeing Stan
socks I didn't really realize what kind
of style statement you could be making
with socks but you can Stan's is amazing
right now you can get yourself some
Stan's socks they have Star Wars
collections they have women's sock
collections that Jenna got with the
Japanese silk how software they babe I'm
they're unbelievable yeah new lines from
Rihanna Willow Smith also they have
holiday lines which you guys can check
out right now I actually tweeted a
picture from the Jenna Jillian podcast
account of all my Stan's socks because I
was like you guys thought I was kidding
about my stance obsession I have so many
Stan socks and what a better gift then
an amazing dance I also receive though
you're gonna give us a pair of socks to
someone your family like wait you got me
socks and look at them be like wow oh
yeah this is dope as hell so check it
out go to Stan's dot-com right now he
sponsor
thank you sponsors so much go to Stan's
for the uncommon thread
thank you guys for always putting up
with her always putting up with our [ __ ]
and also uh you know you do a good job
showing love to the sponsors because it
you know you know that they show love by
accepting the J&J family and you know
for you guys to go you know I've seen a
lot of you guys tweeting at them and
getting their stuff and we appreciate it
we'll help you date them alright you
ready for number five I'm ready here
comes number give it to me baby
Mark Zuckerberg you already know
semi-great is trying to literally plug
us into a mental emotional consciousness
matrix Facebook's Mark Zuckerberg has a
vision for the future a day when people
won't just share posts and videos and
images on social networks but also their
sensory experiences thoughts and
emotions lifted directly from their
brains oh as reported by the Daily Mail
Zuckerberg raised this curious
possibility during a facebook Q&A is
about a year ago I think projecting that
the technology may exist in as little as
50 years beaming thoughts and raw
emotions to others will be as simple as
pressing send something he's described
as the ultimate communication technology
having other people's thoughts and
emotions entering your own mind you can
feel what others feel at what point do
you begin to question which thoughts and
emotions are your own and which were put
there social networks are already
manipulated by marketing and political
interests imagine that happening in your
own head see when when it gets to like
invading my thoughts I am NOT about it I
want this to be my sanctuary where
anything goes hmm
I mean not anything but it's your brain
you don't have it police or monitor your
body in your mind and your consciousness
as far as we know as far as we know so
far as I know yeah we talked about this
with the blood sucking Google watch that
was being referred to as a particle
accelerator yeah your body is the last
thing that you have that is
truly yours in your mind in your
consciousness like everything else way
all your iPhone's listen yeah like your
DNA is the only thing that you have left
that is not infringe on anybody else yes
yep
not if Zuckerberg has something to do
with it I mean imagine how incredibly
invaded you feel like if you had a
thought right and you know like when you
buy something on Amazon and then the
next time you go on your computer it is
those cookies so it'll suggest something
just like what you bought imagine that
but with thoughts like you you think to
yourself you walk into a store and
you're like you know the checker was
really rude to you're like oh that guy
was kind of an [ __ ] and then suddenly
you go on Facebook when you get home and
then it says oh lifted yeah or like our
people who work in customer service at
markets pissing you off
shop online now or something like that
like it reads your [ __ ] brain and
something sometimes I see I'm thinking
of a way beyond that though I feel like
this is only something like our current
technology which is always marketed to
you to be convenient make sure life
better it's easier and in a way
everything is but in theory maybe this
has some more evil purpose than we're
aware of like using your thumbprint in a
gigantic [ __ ] government database if
people are able to access your thoughts
your emotions your raw emotions and
feelings wouldn't you know if you're
Mark Zuckerberg or Facebook or wherever
this goes who is feeling distress right
now who is feeling fear right now you
know maybe you're looking for someone
well that's isn't that their idea my yes
exactly so you know Mark Zuckerberg
might say in an interview it's the
ultimate form of communication yeah is
it or is it the ultimate form of mind
control and surveillance surveillance
that's what it is it's the ultimate
surveillance like Zuka [ __ ] can you
please boy if you don't get your
thoughts out of my thoughts that'd be
great
please look if you [ __ ] like just in
a real practical sense though do you
physically want to feel someone else's
pain you tell me I have a stomach ache I
will take your word for it and I will
help you feel better
I don't want to physically feel your
stomach ache dog no no I don't want to
feel anyone's pain I don't even feel my
own pain especially my own pain yeah
well can you imagine all the people that
are gonna be lifting from their brains
like oh my boyfriend just broke up with
me or like you know I just got really
dark is that really [ __ ] about feels I'm
really dark Tommy I feel like in it in
his future Society where this [ __ ]
happens right they implement this this
thought capturing whatever system
suicides will spike people will feel so
invaded and so like completely just
there's nothing safe anymore yeah and I
really can't even have your mind you
can't think about things you can't you
know a lot of people find solace in in
thought you know myself include I think
everyone does to a certain extent so for
you to feel like that's taken away I
feel like a huge percentage of people
would try to kill themselves well
obviously it's the only way to finally
get peace or whatever finally free
yourself I know it sounds crazy but
prison as it is imagine well traded by
other people what like I can't think of
much worse than than than heaven yeah
and so say this is possible right for
just play along with me for a second
Zuckerberg can make it so you can upload
your thoughts and raw emotions and
feelings onto the Internet who the [ __ ]
is to say that information can't go the
other way the things and thoughts and
mmm can't be uploaded into your brain
backwards yeah
[ __ ] I'm not buying in one second
that things wouldn't they wouldn't spend
infinitely more money trying to do it in
that direction in the other direction
either way I feel like there's so much
room for just like some pure [ __ ]
evil to happen yeah right mm-hmm my
goodness you said that in an interview
pretty [ __ ] a dog I'm not on the same
page as you
I am NOT here for this sucka put like a
[ __ ] [ __ ] please [ __ ] no yeah my brain I
don't like it I like to choose when I
show
even though no I know you know
everything I like to think I keep things
private
you're laughing lots are always being
much all right we got from stranger
dimensions calm just one of my favorite
places I watched to second I frequented
every - well actually stranger
dimensions calm is the first place I
ever found talking about the Berenstain
Berenstein bears mandala fellow pitcher
and uh it's pretty great website all
right yeah I watch two separate videos
being able one was being able and you
watched part of it being able to
essentially Photoshop in audio file so
this guy is creepy well that one was in
the creepiest with the second one's the
creepiest it's called Project volcko by
Adobe and she gives a presentation on
stage where he takes an audio file of
key and Peele
she was sitting on sages and peels the
audio I don't know whatever it was funny
and I he was like yeah I'm gonna go home
and kiss my my dog and my wife and that
order and he's like let's just say that
he wants to change that so he via text
was able to just type in that he wants
to change it so the text identifies the
waveform and then switches it yeah
because you know if you want to edit
audio you can totally just switch those
two things they could do within text to
make it that much faster and easier and
was able to make it sound like he said I
want to go home and kiss my doesn't some
MS or my wife or my dog in that in that
order yeah yeah and it sounds pretty
normal so that's a project that exists
but then Disney research hub had a video
uploaded to their channel it shows you
can record an actor doing a scene or a
line in a couple of different ways and
then being able to manipulate them
together to make whatever desired
outcome you actually want so they have
this other have a bunch of them they had
a girl reading a line really angry and
then she read it again like really sad
and they were able to make it like a
little bit of both or they're able to
make it like the begins you started off
sad and then got angry like to take
selections from different ones yes and
it looks seamless but apparently that
technology already sorted me started
simplified this one is it was very
impressive and directors and producers
like people you'd see why this is a an
important tool for film a time-saver
exactly yeah but there's also a scarier
technology called face to face that
allows someone so let me just describe
to the video and the video is crazy
because they're only using like
political leaders to show how their
product works um a guy Kermit a guy was
sitting standing next to a screen where
you see George W Bush talking about
whatever you talk about there's no audio
this program allows the software to read
like your Julian's facial expressions
whatever they are yeah and then project
them through george w bush's face so
even though it's different video in a
pre-recorded video alright so even
though it's still his face
you are now controlling his facial
expressions so this is a it's a video
george w bush like really sad about
something and i'm laughing in it could
make him like i'ma moding in a plane
recorded if he's dead
think about that though i mean the idea
of being able to manipulate video and
audio to this extent is terrifying yeah
well like this this specificity of of
the emotion or the demeanor of one's
face when they're talking on video is
something that you know is like sacred
you're like I can't [ __ ] alter I mean
obviously CGI is this but this isn't CGI
right right no not at all yeah so that's
the thing is that people are very
skeptical of CGI we do know that
Holograms exist and that we can make a
person into a hologram so people are a
little bit skeptical of you know you
can't trust everything that you see but
imagine now you see this very important
video coming from Donald Trump
our current president elect mm-hm except
guess who's over there making all of his
facial expressions and editing some fun
software making his words and stuff
change in the audio it's look it's that
amir Putin over there making plain face
games and audio talk I'm gonna back away
because it's a little but it's weird
that's [ __ ] wild to think but the way
that they demonstrated it in the video
was all political leaders like tell me
you could just showed me with anybody
like anybody in the world any actor an
actress no you choose to show me how
you're gonna manipulate george w bush's
face because they want to freak you out
it's not if you're if you're if you're
if you're willing enough to visit this
corner of the internet and believe
whatever we want to freak you out so
we're going to use political leaders for
this [ __ ] video fair enough
but it is possible to using these two
softwares together or things like that
to just make a completely fake video
that looks outrageously realism couldn't
believe anything you watch that it work
well I think that's the ultimate
takeaway of that is like oh just cause
you saw a video doesn't even really mean
that that's real at all yeah yeah I mean
I know you saw all those conspiracy
theories about Barack Obama in front of
green screens or like Hillary Clinton in
front of green screens or that there's
theories that some of these are
Holograms or yes a lot of a possible
technology in terms of video all right
modifying or manipulating software
exists already like mind-blowing [ __ ]
right but for it to be so accessible and
so easy to enable on certain things like
without you know needing an expert it's
wild to think about right
anyways bugging on and [ __ ] up we got
one more I have two more last one so
really one that project monarch is that
what that no this is not the last one no
it's two more the last ones really
whatever all right this is also from
stranger dimensions calm
it's called project monarch why are you
reading this before I even tell you
because I didn't realize that wasn't
alarm okay the monarch butterfly every
year millions of these golden winged
insects migrate south to a small area of
pine groves in central Mexico which
consists of only about 70 square miles
the process of this journey has amazed
scientists for years because the time it
takes for the migration to occur is
actually longer than the lifespan of a
monarch butterfly which is about six to
eight weeks this means this means their
offspring born during
migration simply knows where to go and
carries on from there call it instinct
in fact many wonder if there isn't some
kind of genetic memory at work something
hardwired or programmed within them that
tells that guides them and their actions
towards their goal this is something
that exists in many animals possibly
even in humans like the bird's ability
to build a nest or the turtles
compulsion to bask on a sunny day but
the monarch butterfly is a symbol of
something else a different kind of
programming that is said to permeate our
modern society and control millions of
people throughout the world project
monarch as the story goes project
monarch was part of a covert CIA
operation known as MKULTRA which began
in 1953 and it would also later be
attributed to the Illuminati and is
allegedly still used today under project
monarch victims usually young children
are subjected to intense trauma
inflicted to the point at which their
minds dissociate from the experience
this causes a form of multiple
personality disorder allowing the quote
programmer or handler to mold these
dissociated minds into new controllable
personalities from there the triggers or
alters are put in place with in popular
media and other sources that quote
trigger and cause these mind controlled
quote slaves to perform whatever actions
they have been programmed to do there
are also various stages or types of
programming each tuned to specific types
of individuals and serving different
purposes alpha programming for example
leads to increase memory ability and
greater physical strength while Delta
programming exists to remove fear and
ensure that orders are followed until
the very last breath what's the end goal
of all this control of course while
these types of mind-control conspiracies
aren't necessarily unique there's also
the Nazi marionette programming MKULTRA
program as well as its precursors
project artichoke and project Bluebird
actually existed D CIA operations sought
to understand hypnosis new interrogation
methods forced of addictions behavioral
engineering and yes mind-control among
other things a plethora of strange and
let's face it shady undertakings what's
most compelling perhaps even iconic
about the
mind control however is that these
triggers and patterns can allegedly be
found in much of popular media which is
all over the internet I'm sure you guys
are aware of those I've written about
Illuminati imagery the Eye of Providence
and its place in popular culture culture
but monarch mind control is a bit
different
these are icons and images placed around
just to say AHA we're right here and you
don't even know it these triggers are
put in place allegedly to control the
minds of their pre-programmed sleeves
and initiate a response put into MKULTRA
well I mean or if you're talking about
genetic memory maybe you're the kids of
someone of a cousin or whatever okay
people in fact those who have been
programmed likely don't even know they
are under control at all once triggered
they're programmed personalities will
surface and they'll be like dancers on a
string here are just a few of the
suppose example the law there's a bunch
of stuff in there like obviously like
Lady Gaga music videos and anything
that's to do with butterflies or monarch
programming but I mean who's to say that
maybe that's not a [ __ ] date that
exists yeah that's all I can do later
like the relax song musics don't do it
it isn't the killer premonition I've
I've read articles I forget I was
reading but it was for another podcast I
think where people claim I forget it's
that's called something a certain
phenomenon where people claim that they
just feel like they're supposed to do
something and one day a lot I feel it
and they don't know what but they feel
like a song which is gonna go off and
they're gonna have to do something and
that's prolly be speculated to have
something to do with this pretty
programming yeah I mean I'm Kayla I've
done a little reading on MKULTRA and
that [ __ ] is very fascinating I was
scary because when we were researching
for the don't hug me i'm scared theories
that was one of them it was like a
parallel between don't hug me I'm scared
and MKULTRA I like the way that they're
you know how they like lose their minds
you know in every episode at some point
and like they change form and things are
looking [ __ ] up and torturous and dark
it's supposed like a lot of the theories
are like it's some sort of a flashback
or some sort of
memoral II memory bursts of like having
been gone through those programs Chiefs
but ya know that the deeper you get into
things like that the more you just kind
of get like scared and all the [ __ ] you
think exists that you don't know because
like MKULTRA is something that like it's
a program that was kept so secret that
like went on and it was so wrong
yeah but the fact that it existed and
like was documented makes you so
terrified because it's like what the
[ __ ] else went on right that we didn't
know about but I didn't know well I mean
think of all that I mean if anyone buys
into the predictive programming or
whatever in the media think of all the
shows and things that you love like
stranger things like of the government
doing these experiments on people and
mind-control and that kind of thing and
what happens in the society where that
happens
it's [ __ ] scary man it's pretty
[ __ ] crazy yeah well I mean do you
just let me know in the comments if you
think you're being pre-programmed what
we can do to if there's a lot of people
who have had moments and I think that's
a weird kind of thing that I would I
would say I might have had to or it's
like you you feel like you're supposed
to do something or some or go somewhere
and not like others over sensors I do
today know it's like yeah it's a
different feeling than that like I
notice yeah but I mean I I can identify
with someone who may have claimed to
have felt that like that's a real thing
and then you know my mind is I've never
felt like someone's inner switch on and
I got to do something well you don't you
don't feel like like out of everything
we've talked about I feel like that's
the most graspable thing that I could be
like oh someone told me that they really
felt that they had a higher purpose or
something very specifically needed to do
or else and they they can like it they
would tell me in person like this is how
I felt I would be like okay that's
that's something I can not just like you
know brush off my shoulder be like
that's crazy I can't argue with how
someone feels well yes but you can also
just I feel like you can kind of just
innately relate to something like that
because of you know deja vu and things
like that where you just like it you
don't know how to explain
but you're feeling something that's
there mentally and this is just another
one of those things where it's like
someone might have really felt oh you're
saying you're pre-programmed
no I'm saying I get it like I understand
what that might feel like if someone
were to tell me there so you're saying
you prefer good and don't you think TBB
you people being when some people get
[ __ ] oh I can't relate to that feeling
at all I've never felt like something's
if she's gonna switch off and I'm gonna
have something to do well I never had
that feeling all I'm saying is that if
someone were to tell me that they've had
it I can trap all right let's over on
this is the last one uh for signs it's
really only two okay that your dog has
seen a ghost
you you I feel like you forget sir come
on all right I watched this video a lot
um this you know please stop digging at
me baby I love you so much
you go see your girl number one looking
through the air with eyes following
something invisible Marvel does that
every day
yeah every day yes he does well I mean
all of these really only two of these
because the next one is um like barking
growling or hissing there's a bunch of
videos of dogs doing it on YouTube like
it corners and like walls or at doorways
or whatever by this logic though Marvel
sees a thousand ghosts a day I think it
depends a lot on you that's we don't yet
all the time that make sense oh but I
think it also you can't just say like oh
if your dog growls or hisses when
there's nothing there it's a good make
yeah
that's not fair marble just gets set off
by everything yeah and he hears and he's
listening for it it's like they do this
thing where they get in this mood where
they really want to patrol marble no no
hold on hold on
it's marbles and Kermit because Kermit
is the onion who has learned exactly
from watching him do it and they do this
thing where they both post up and stare
at the front door and any tiny peep that
comes from that direction they will
freak out over yeah but I mean they're
starting to do
it's very specific they're listening for
something but I was going to say that
they do this marble does this thing
where he'll get excited and then he'll
like run and look at karmic because he
wants Kermit to also go with him yeah
yeah do you mean like he doesn't just go
chase it by himself 24/7 like sometimes
he like get he like barbs next car
makers and try and get yeah it plays
into it they do it with each other and
then they'll start barking at each other
and then they get each other to go do
the same I mean talk about Zuckerberg
marbles is mind controlling Kermit he is
my controlling curve it's just this
thoughtless minion who's like I'm gonna
just get controlled hey my new work he
just says manipulated right and left
don't you see and just a little guy you
just rescued him from peach no she's
gonna play he's not having a PG that's
now all right
um but yeah barking or hissing when
something's not there the third one is
ignoring you and I guess this applies
more to cats like if if they're just
ignoring you and looking at something
else but I feel like that means your cat
is seeing ghosts more than 24 [ __ ] 7
okay this is a dick and fear of the
unknown
ready either lilybeth shared a story two
years ago that exemplifies our final
sign that your pet has seen a ghost fear
she had recently moved into an old house
with her grandparents the place was
about a hundred years old and and in her
words creepy one night she and her dog
Lola we're about to go to bed but Lola
began to act strangely she jumped up and
went to the bed's edge as if to look
over her eyes then began follow
something up in the air something
invisible I would call her name and she
wouldn't move lilybeth wrote she turned
on the light to see perhaps if Lola was
being pestered by a fly or a mouse which
she saw nothing then as if in fear Lola
curled up against lilybeth occasionally
glancing over the edge of the bed
throughout the night I don't like that
story at all in fact I wish I had never
heard it well I mean you've seen them
okay but also just to debunk real quick
Kermit is afraid of everything all the
time but we've seen member we saw wait
you do that a couple times yeah I don't
like to think about that yeah two creeps
me out
it creeps me out every time that we move
or like you move into a new house
versus always like a big Paris agent
thanks to Rome cuz she got me on that
sage train should get me that nice sage
and we liked all the corners of
everything on fire
what's a run home drought you mean drone
stop I was talking about son and
daughter I don't know what around was
Rome thanks to Rome the person alright
sorry continue
I always get scared every time that we
move that that you're gonna bring the
dogs over for the first time after
you've already signing your lease and
everything and they're just gonna refuse
to walk in the front door because your
whole [ __ ] house is haunted that's
legitimate fear of mine well it's the
worst case scenario you invest no the
worst case scenario is buying a home
that's haunted well that's what I mean
it's like people you invest all this
money and time and effort in switching
homes and the move and then you finally
are all done and you're like oh great
like a tight there are spirits are tight
tight tight yeah
tensions have high tide well this is a
good weird podcast I like weed stuff I
like weird [ __ ] if you guys have any
experiences with any of these things or
opinions or if you just want to write
the word ink comment below and we'll
read them yes please do Kermit oh my god
peaches done that three times then
hopefully she saw that three times me
this this podcast you guys are gonna dog
Dodd cats are cats there you go pink dog
pink dog dog dog thank you guys for
hanging out with us sorry I'm tired and
I said Anna no I appreciate that you're
here you know think of him you mean a
lot we'll be back next week with another
podcast and she's leaking the money
she's looking to my good girl yeah check
out the sponsors links in the
description and have a great week guys
your sign
[Music]